Hello, everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to my public Discord server.
Now whether or not it was a good idea to make a public discord server
is not what I'm here to talk about.
In fact, when I first decided to do this
I was only curious if I could actually break discord altogether.
Short answer is yes, I could,
and long answer is yes, I did.
But what came out of it actually surprised me.
I divided the server up into various rooms that you'd find in my house
in Markiplier Manor
which is the name of the discord server.
Now you've got the attic,
the study,
your brother's room, your sister's room,
the bathroom, the basement, the backyard, the jacuzzi
You've got a whole bunch of different rooms and each of these rooms have been
subdivided into a wonderful culture of people that are weird and wonderful
and awful and great
But I'm not here to talk about the community, no.
I realized that there was one thing very lacking in this entire server
And that's a place to relieve some tension
-- and no, oddly enough that's not in the bathroom
I'm talking about a place where you can vent your frustrations to the open air
and everyone and anyone can participate at any time
and very most likely all at once
This... is my screaming room
*horrible noise*
So here's the thing: in discord you can make a public voice Channel
I've got various ones here that people can talk to,
they've got limits on the number of users that can be in
I've got a team of moderators that are helping keeping it all sane,
But, what I wanted is to make a room that was entirely dedicated just to venting frustration
in whatever manner you saw fit
and so that is all the introduction that I'm gonna do
because right now I need to find out if it's gonna work
because honestly, I don't even know.
You'd think that I would tell my moderators about this beforehand
But I'm not gonna do that and it's not because I'm a douche...
Eh?!
That is..
surprising
Welcome to the screaming room.
In this place everyone can chat all at the same time
This is a place where you can vent your frustrations
So feel free to do so; you will not be punished,
you will not be reprimanded.
Feel free to do whatever you want
Oh, I'm just waiting for someone to randomly scream.
Yeah
*Screams*
There it is.
*Screaming*
Hell yeah!
*More screaming*
*Moan*
*Screaming continues*
Monika No!
Monika no not today!
*O C E A N   M A N *
*Screaming gets louder*
*Screaming continues*
[Mark] Honestly, I'm not impressed by your use of the screaming room.
*Screaming gets even louder*
*Screaming gets even louder than before*
*Screaming goes on for a while*
Blissful silence...
These are the great things that you can expect out of my discord server.
It's available to the public for the next six hours only,
in fact, it maybe less right now depending on how long it takes me to edit this video.
But if you want to join up my discord server, there's a link down in the description.
It will only be open for a few hours.
As of right now, there's already well over 9,000 people online
And um...
I believe the server has a total membership of 40
-- about 42,000 people which is gonna go up anytime soon.
So if you want to join the best discord server on the entire internet,
click the link in the description below.
You don't have very long and it's crashing right now,
So uh...
We'll see you there.
Alright guys.
Thanks everybody so much for watching and uh
as always
Well actually, before I go,
let me create a few
-- in fact, just for you guys, I'm actually gonna create a few new
uh, text channels.
I'm gonna call...
I'm gonna have...
thank you everybody so much for watching
Hope to see you on the discord server, and, uh, it's probably gonna break by the time you see this video
So thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always,
I will see you in the next video
Bye, bye!